well hello everyone like I said as of
yesterday I'm on vacation for two weeks
so I'm gonna be streaming some games in
the morning like this so if any of you
want to join or drop a challenge feel
free to do so
hey Jenkins how's it going man you up
for a game
a swipe a and please maybe only three
minute games or or less so you know more
people can play so either one minute two
minute or three minutes okay
maybe with a one-second increment or two
seconds wouldn't be a problem
hey Ahmed oh you won't get destroyed
Jenkins it's not nothing not an issue
it's a it's a good way to practice okay
we have a challenge from crazy Butler so
I I set up this new interface so now the
board is a bit larger so I think it will
be better this way and I managed to to
get some more space on the camera okay
very nice Jenkins so let's see we're
playing against crazy Butler will play
will play the Italian Bishop c4 and
let's go for the b4 I always like this
before move whenever I can play it so in
this case at the Evans gambit I'm
listening to some music I hope it's not
too loud
okay going for that center very nice
crazy Butler isn't interested in
grabbing a pawn I like it I like it so
just go Bishop to e3 Abdul what do you
mean you can't watch the video is there
a problem with the video so I'm just
gonna capture here too and not allow him
to castle if he captures back okay he
did capture back so I think it's gonna
be a bit of a problem for him to Castle
now yeah I'm interested to see how crazy
Butler will solve this castling problem
[Music]
he might even go for the queenside
castle but we'll see okay now how do I
develop my knight okay we'll go to b3
and then bring this rook to d1 I think I
think that should be a good plan
ah that's how he's gonna Castle okay I
don't mind but this is given up this e5
pawn so maybe I don't even have to take
it let me just check okay I will take it
and then play rook to d1
to kind of butter this Bishop a little
[Music]
and also this night is well it's not
feeling very good okay so I can win a
rook here so I'm just gonna do it
without too much thinking should be okay
for me so okay I am giving up a pawn but
I don't know he's not interested in the
pawn so let's just grab it okay and well
since this Knight is protecting this
Bishop I'm just going to attack the
knight so this Bishop is gonna fall in
the next move now I'm not playing the
tournament now I'm just gonna play some
free games
oh he has that okay I guess I missed
that one not okay I guess I'll grab a
phone I'm gonna go visit the c6 okay
this isn't a good move
let just go here yeah I'll go here so
now if he goes Bishop to c7 if he goes
to c7
I'll think of something
stop eating pneumonia lemon I would like
to listen to some music or watch
probably uh
okay let's defend this form he can't
really attack it with anything else it
since it's on a dark square so let's
just push this pawn as well
Thank You meter okay now how do we
improve here how do we improve okay
we're just gonna go like this I know you
want to meet your college named Anya but
I I don't have mr. college although my
dad is a big fan
ah I'm talking to pneumonia and I I drop
upon should do more playing and less
talking
well it will get more subscribers oh
okay I'm not gonna grab the Queen just
because he's long time cuz well I think
my position is better okay we have
Patrick but with an unlimited amount of
time so Patrick please a challenge you
know to a three minute or less we can't
really play a game on the string with
unlimited time well there are enough
chess people in the world okay why did I
play six I never play the French
although chess is becoming more popular
and popular especially in Saint Louis
but when chess becomes a like a subject
in schools then I think then I think
almost everyone will play chess
ok swipe a has a good position yeah I
have no idea why I played the French
never in my life have I once played a
French defense well if you if f mother
you're the one I declined it's because
you challenged me to an unlimited time
game like I said please please challenge
to a three minutes or less game my
friend is still sleeping but he will
come Paul he likes to get his beauty
sleep
my puppy is in the kitchen
I think it will
especially with as part of doing such
immense work I think it actually will
become a subject in schools I mean in
Russia it's a subject for many years
yeah like Danzo says okay we have this
night move worst worst the night gonna
go I'm very interested to see what swipe
I had in mind you will probably have to
capture on f7 so I'm not playing any
fancy moves or anything I'm just playing
normal moves and see and see what swipe
a can come up with this month I turned
30 her wish for is it urge urge 38 yeah
like I said he will have to cut for an
f7 for no reason I mean there was
nowhere to retreat to retreat denied -
okay now this move this is kind of a
nice move because now he's attacking my
bishop on d6 but I think Bishop their
faith solves all my problems
okay let's just bring our queen into the
game somehow let's play Bishop here to
defend this pawn no problem Joe no cream
or is it Yannick Ihram simply drop a
challenge and we can play okay
swipe it just parted with his queen so
I'm fortunate for him okay
who do we have next we have the jumping
toaster okay let's go efore or if you're
on leeches janaki rama just drop a
challenge and no problem okay we we have
the fringe defense so I will Knight c3
that's what I always play there is no
link you just have to go to leeches and
right eigen matter that's all there is
play some gambits well there aren't
really that many gametes in the French
defense but okay I will try yeah I play
on chess calm but only bullet and not
that often because I mostly play
tournaments and the tournaments are well
a lot better on leeches well I hope I
hope jumping toaster doesn't allow 20g
for check because well that would just
end the game immediately and he doesn't
he covers it up nicely so very nice very
nice move by chess toaster I will ignore
this rook here
although I can go Queen to f3 Queen f3
seems okay and then after we shoot at
five Yago Queen f3 and maybe go for the
queenside castle now just the threaten
this Queen to g3 check for fun yeah okay
I will try some gambits my chest at fam
username is also a GAD matter and
unfortunately jumping toaster allows
this Queen to g3 check so so
unfortunately the game is over okay we
have s for sham 95 lobby I will come to
your study but not now odd Jenkins you
were jumping toaster it's okay I mean it
was a good game but you shouldn't have
allowed this taking it good luck to you
as well okay we have a lot of challenges
so we have a long night of six all the K
but Ron is here he probably played for
the entire night and now he will crush
me as that usually goes my friend will
not allow me to go for my Benoni so I
will just play some passive moves
[Music]
if you guys will be interested I could
make a tournament maybe even tomorrow
you know for four subscribers and four
well for anyone who wants to play really
unleashes it will be like a tournament
between subscribers and we have a
challenge from pneumonia
very nice oh it's my move okay just
develop how well these are not rated
games these are casual games Paul since
if yours are off comes will be playing
on my account so it it wouldn't be okay
if it was a rated game three top
openings this black well it depends what
white plays if white plays d4 well my
top openings are definitely the benoni
the Banco gambit well it's a branch of
the benoni and well actually like all
defenses would like against d4 but but
Benoni Banco gambit and maybe maybe even
the groom Phil but I think King's Indian
the tops groom fold and also lately I
have been playing the Stonewall you know
with the f4 f5
[Music]
well yours out of yours auto always beat
me when we play a blitz or bullet but if
we play a long game then we're about
equal if we play a tournament game with
one and a half hour because you're
thought of is extremely good at openings
he knows opening so well so it's very
hard to play a fast game against him but
I'm not I'm not that good in fast games
in general I always prefer a long game
hey Demetria nice to see you I checked
your game it was a very nice game very
nice game with the white pieces and a
very nice checkmate ok so let's see
what's this Knight doing here I don't
think he's really doing anything but do
I really need h6
he is giving me a pawn here so I'm just
gonna take it I'm interested to see what
he does
[Music]
okay like I said I will take the pawn so
if he attacks my knight then he will
also be attacking this this point three
times but we'll see how that goes
well if you if you'll be interested I
could create the tournament tomorrow
okay we already have so much challenges
or ten challenges yeah like I said he
will attack this pawn but I had this
Knight to e6 move which attacks his
bishop and also if he captures with the
knight then F captures and e6 will
protect this pawn so I kind of like this
move but we'll see it's a blitz game not
enough time to calculate everything
if he doesn't capture okay so Bishop to
e3 was better because of this 96 move I
think
and he does capture so okay this bone is
nicely protected now okay he plays the
bishop here I will try to exchange it
since it's a very annoying Bishop I
don't have any more coffee this is the
last coffee I had okay so we wrap up on
and our position is pretty good don't
really see any moves for why this Knight
b5 is annoying but not really doing
anything thank you Chris Richardson well
it's a nice it's a nice way to you know
get to know people who watch my channel
and and I'd be playing either way and
leeches so you know why not stream
okay patron you can't play that's a
shame
I was hoping to see to see your
improvement
okay so what's our plan here okay
maybe I shouldn't have played this rock
and see it maybe D H was better and okay
well I can't capture with the pawn but I
have two other pieces that can capture
this night so it's kind of a blunder
yeah I know Dimitri you challenge me
I received your challenge well I don't
really play blitz on leeches so I don't
know my highest rating was mm and maybe
50 but I do play bullet on bullet I got
around
I think 21 70 or 2150 but like I said
I'm not I'm not that good in fast games
I'm a lot better in classical good game
to you as well okay next we have next we
have Vishal
it's a 2200 rated player okay so this
will be very interesting I will go for
my Stonewall for this game always a
pleasure to play a high rated opponent
we'll see how my opponent does against
the Stonewall no no I'm not and I am
definitely I'm well I have to I have to
win a couple of more games to achieve
the rank of candidate master but
definitely not and I am I haven't I
played maybe one he's really going with
this H pawn so I don't think this is
this is good for this opening but okay
he is the highest rated player so maybe
he will teach me
okay I would like to play Knight here
and here but first I would like to get
my Bishop to c6 and put my rope to c8
because this Queen I don't really like
this Queen and c2 yes that's the reason
now he will go f3 but I don't think f3
is even possible in this position but
like I said he will teach me something
well thank you for your compliment Danzo
but I assure you that is not the case I
don't I play nothing like and I am and
he goes for this move and well capturing
here would probably well I will capture
here to get this route to c8 move
although he will close the line would be
captures on the c3 but I don't know I
think black is better here and I think
like is a lot better here so we'll see I
really don't see any any plans for white
he does have this push but again it's
very hard to push this I will capture
here and now threaten the Queen so I'm
threatening Bishop to a4 and even if he
prevents it I will play Bishop to a4 and
then make a rook lift yes I will play it
now so and now I will threaten this move
I don't think I don't think white is
doing ok here but then again he is a
2200 rated player 4 a.m. and you're
still watching that's that's amazing man
okay now how do we how do we go about
this hmm I I don't really like this rook
here so I'm just gonna attack it
it's quite annoying and yeah he does
have to play this I will capture and
okay this check isn't possible but I
will bring it my other rook into the
game he will go there okay I'm very
interested to see what it does because
if he goes here well now he'll just have
to give up his queen and I don't think I
don't think I want to capture his queen
right now as there are probably better
moves to play so let's just let's just
exchange this bishop first this will
allow me to bring my queen here he will
play it like that okay
as as I thought he would let's go here
he captures here I don't know it could
be kind of dangerous for white I don't
really like this but like I said he does
have some some things to play yes I
don't want to allow this I probably
could have played that better and he
does want to draw maybe I can win this
but I'm low on time so yeah we had to
draw this but a very nice game by we
shall and although I think my position
was better he as a high rated opponent
showed that it's not enough to play a
good game you have to play a game till
the end so very nice game biracial I
[Music]
we're not doing rematches we shall like
I said maybe if if you win a game then a
rematch will we have head but there are
too much challenges for me to play
rematches
okay let's go Bishop to b3 yeah I was
just thinking the same thing the Enzo
that well not not just the top ten oh I
don't want to pre-move not just top ten
players but you know it's a long time
since 2500 was the barrier to achieve
the rank of Grandmaster and now you
already have 2800 players so you know it
takes you about 100 ratings to get from
an iamb to a grandmaster and then you
have Magnus Carlsen with almost eighteen
hundred and thirty now so there should
definitely be a super GM title Thank You
Vishal for for a very nice game so a
very hard game in the morning maybe
maybe if it was a longer game I would go
for the win but I respected your rating
and I was I was actually very happy with
a drop with the black pieces yeah even
even 3200 on bullets achieved by penguin
I think and yeah Nakamura has 3300 in
chess come on one occasion actually okay
how are we doing here okay so I have a
pawn and I guess I'll just capture here
and this is pretty good for me you're
Bobby Woodson and Omar well if you
challenge me I will play you of course
man
so such a shame I have no more coffee
well naka is so good at bullet because I
don't know well someone has to be the
best and he's the best larvae I will
accept your challenge but you have to
wait in line we have crazy Butler next
than Mamun then paid for RS for a bullet
game empty lotto swipe a meat cake a
night's hack and well a couple of other
players as well
okay night to be four I will capture
here so if he captures this I don't know
getting himself into a pin like that I
don't like it
yeah but it's hard to tell if if you
ever watch stream bite albarran the
Israeli Grandmaster he has this well
saying the art of bullet and it really
is an art because you really do have to
make decisions fast and it's more about
not making the wrong move than about
making the right move
I think okay name Anya how do you how do
you play this this was rugby 8 was a
high you will play it like that okay but
this drops a piece unfortunately you're
not slow it's it's better to take your
time and play a good game then play fast
and you know just to make the moves okay
I will I will take that sure
so unfortunately for pneumonia I'm up a
piece let's see if pneumonia can can mix
it up somehow I hope everything is okay
with the stream it says here that my
stream is of medium health so I hope
nothing is lagging so just improve our
night here or any of you Game of Thrones
fans and if so what did you think of the
first episode okay
pneumonia is is going fast
supposed to take back okay yeah sure you
can take back but you have to take back
another move if this is what you're
going for
okay so yeah you probably want to take
here as I imagined but no take-backs can
can bring your piece back it was boring
you thought it was boring I thought it
was very good I don't know
my girlfriend also says she thought it
was boring but I like these long
conversations well you're probably not
the only one who never watched it
well Stefan resigned so let's go to our
next challenge with a crazy Butler good
game nemanja comparing to the last
episode huh calendar
yeah Aria moments are a thing of
interest now I kind of knew what was
going to happen I don't know if you're
talking about me then so no I'm not
married although I I do live with my
girlfriend for for many years now so
pretty much it's the same Bishop to g5 I
don't I don't encounter this move a lot
in this variation but I don't know
doesn't seem wrong let's see what crazy
Butler does
and he goes at four very very aggressive
hashtag meadow matter is marriage in the
kitchen sleeping he's not interested in
today's stream he just had a long walk
well I could tell you what time okay
well he is offering me to capture this
g2 porn but would that be good for me
unfortunately it wouldn't
III do have to play 95 first what is
okay here actually what is okay here he
if he goes 93 he's okay or even this
yeah what is okay here it's no problem
I'm just gonna go see five and try to
maybe get an open C file and see how
crazy Butler deals with it I can't
really read your name mister hello from
Ukraine but hello to you too we'll just
go knight c6 to really go after this
pawn so he will play c3
thanks Jason ma'am
if you as well are interested in a game
feel free to challenge okay now what do
we have this be Foursquare just open but
I think I'll just put my broken c84 for
future for future plays and maybe go for
this c4 square with Knight to a5 or to
simply go for this I will I will go for
the Queen exchange here so if he
captures I will get a temple on this
Bishop and win this C file which i think
is the most important file in this game
for the tournament well I could tell you
9:00 a.m. but that's 9 a.m. in Croatia
so you would have to figure out what
time that would be in your time zone but
you are definitely 9 a.m. a nice
tournament a 1-hour tournament even and
three minute games okay so our queen is
attacked what do we do we have to be
careful or maybe he will trap our queen
it's going to be three a good move it's
hard to say or should i retreat with the
Queen hmm if going to be three okay
let's go Queen to b3 well now it is
10:00 a.m. in the morning 10:00 a.m. and
10 minutes to be exact
and crazy Butler is playing a very good
game I'm actually almost doing one
minute
yeah it's 10:10 in Croatia now thank you
thank you name Anja
so okay our friend here is tricking me
into taking env2 so he can play Bishop
287 check a very nice a very nice tactic
by crazy Butler so I will have to
retreat unfortunately and he's going
after me so hard
he will probably try to get his queen to
d3 and tried to checkmate me on 87
because he he doesn't really have a lot
of time so he has to yeah and now he's
preparing this move so we'll just we'll
just capture the Queen and grab the
spawn we have to do that
yeah the bishop is attacked although I
don't really want to capture here so I
will play this move rather yeah I think
this is much better for me maybe now he
won't allow it okay man yeah a very good
game that crazy Butler it's also 10:10
in Egypt that's quite the information
and here is my moon and petal Juarez is
next with his famous bullet game came a
moon no is it my moon yeah I don't know
if my moon is in the stream and we have
a Sicilian so like I said every time
someone plays a Sicilian I will play
before because I think it's a it's a
very fun move to play especially in the
Blitz game and our friend isn't
interested in capturing so we'll just
play this Bishop here and the tech is
rook and I think I think it will be very
hard for black to play this now larvae
you have to wait in line everybody waits
in line I can't accept you before turn
because all the challenges are placed
chronologically so it wouldn't be fair
if I accepted your challenge before
everyone else hello Karl gomez get to
see you man
we'll just attack this rook here
although capturing with the knight was
probably better
for why there I said already this month
I turned 30 well last month I kind of
still think it's June and our opponent
is giving me a rook here so I will I
will take it and go for this Knight g5
move so black seems in a lot of trouble
now yeah 18 with 12 years experience
that's a nice way to put it okay I have
so much challenges I should we should
really play four games
I mean faster games okay most of them
are three minutes so that's fine thank
you mister dare for this belated
birthday and mr. Mamun is allowing me to
play this Bishop to f7 check so so
unfortunately I will play it here and
there and we have Petra Juarez with a
bullet game okay I would quite a lot so
thank you bet for RS again for
challenging me to a bullet let's see how
better RS fares this game and he
captures with the seat bone which does
block my bishop so we'll just have to
reroute our Bishop somewhere else like
here Thank You mr. rorish and he is very
fast okay
mmm what to play I will give him my
bishop here attack the Queen but this
allows that for but it's okay I don't
mind this f4 move he goes there okay I
do like this point these pawns are very
nice and he's really going after me if I
go here there's nowhere for me to go
next so that's not happening so very
nice by mr. rorish I will capture here
and he does want to threaten my bishop
so oh I like his position very much this
could be very dangerous for me he wants
to play Knight to f6 but I will try to
exchange Queens so we have that I will
make a check here and go here just not
to allow any checks so I will capture
here and go here and I think my bishop
is stronger although he doesn't really
have any time left on the clock so and
[Music]
we have empty lot oh and the mid K is
next so let's go I will go for my v6
move again okay but let's play e5 c5
allows for much better games McGregor ok
we'll capture
I see a lot of people discussing
McGregor everyday yeah well he wasn't
losing he was just I mean he had a nice
position although a couple of a couple
of more precise moves maybe would have
done the trick
well you don't need norms for cm or FM
title only for I am and the GM the only
rating
yes everyone knows that you are better
RS but I'm not sure how to pronounce it
is it was the Earth's our post dear car
so I will just say petrol we have 9 f3
and well I do want to play this Bishop
to d6 but I kinda have to develop my
other pieces as well
don't don't really want to play with the
same piece okay name anya i will skip
you for now until you say it's okay
empty lot o empty alot oh so okay it's a
nice position for white I will not play
h6 because I don't really consider it's
necessary so I'll just try and develop
all my pieces and well empty lot Oh
makes it a bit easier for me well for CM
it's 20 104 FM well you also have a
national master which is like 2250 but
for FM I think it's 2300 yeah yeah Zaman
is correct and empty lotto goes g4 which
weakens his Queen King side quite a bit
I probably could have even captured on
g4 but I just played Bishop to g6 a bit
too soon
[Music]
okay how do we go about this move well
we'll pin the night first
[Music]
it's it's a very nice questions why pay
I know I never played a match against
King crusher
I played one hyper bullet game against
him and he beat me but to be fair it did
take me about 10 seconds to turn on
recording but he would probably beat me
King crusher is very strong I think he
at one point he was 2500 in bullet and
he plays every day he's a very
experienced player KMT lot oh this this
isn't this is a very good position for
white let's see what what I can do here
if he captures the bishop I don't really
mind so I would just try to double up
here yes I agree that Cheska might be a
bit more accurate as it has more players
and you have beaten King crusher well
congratulations man it's not a small
thing beating King crusher okay so he
won this file but not for long I will
play rook to e8 next and well it's about
the position is about equal so empty
although I think plays a lot better than
his rating would suggest
thank you see right or is it Siraj I
don't know but I'm sure we will get a
chance to play although I do have 18
challenges at this moment so a lot of
people enjoy chess in the morning it
seems well I like both chess calm and
leeches but like I said I think
tournaments and HSL are a lot better so
I'm just gonna if he exchanges this will
he will play played like this okay I
will go at five here how do you get to
play game fracture so much you play in
the same tournaments as he does analysis
is also free and chess calm okay to some
extent okay what do we play here
he goes c4 uh Kayla's just threatened
this pawn here usually only chess well
I've seen I've seen like 30,000 okay I
don't know if I should capture this I
kind of think that capturing an h3
should be enough to win the game so I'm
just gonna do it I'm well French defense
is one defense I never play hey from
five to fifteen thousand y'okay that
could be the the average although I did
see thirty thousand at one occasion okay
so our friend plays this just capture
here so don't think don't think he can
do anything it's pretty much over
okay if I go here then we have this nice
check here I think this will be enough
to win he will put his Queen there Wow
yeah I didn't want to take the Queen but
seems I will
what did he play uh he resigned okay so
and we are against the mid K next round
which time did I pronounce it right
first time Syria or Siraj the second
time let's see what mitt K what media
plays me K goes c5 again I will go
before even though before is not a good
move in this position I think I think
it's fine for blitz
thank you see right Siraj huh I'm very
glad you enjoyed them I'll just push a 5
here see see how my friend meet Kate
deals with this and even f4 now just the
Perez this night I really don't like him
there Bishop c4 let's threaten checkmate
here so okay we have e 6 I'm just gonna
Castle here and even go f5 now since I
meet K decided to leave your skin in the
center we should definitely break open
the center so I'm interested to see how
meat gate of course he will capture so
very nice move and what now he will play
this ok
do I give up a piece I don't think so I
will just take here Mitka is a dangerous
player could I could I capture here
let's see what mid K thinks about this
how he plays it although he does have
Queen to d4 check
I wonder if Mitka will see this if he
sees this then it's pretty much over for
me but meet K doesn't didn't see it so
let's go c3 just to prevent this and
there is a site update in progress so I
think we'll be unable to play any moves
now yours are up separating in real life
is 2100 yeah we have a network error
since there is a site upgrade in
progress your sorrows rating is 20 130 I
think in real life okay I will capture
here he is threatening this subway
uh-huh okay
our opponent wants to make a die take it
back yeah that's a better move so I will
have to play this although he could
sacrifice here so I don't really have a
choice I will have to play this move
although he could just capture now meet
K is completely in a winning position
here so I hope he doesn't I hope he
doesn't mess it up it's a very nice move
or up the g5 is there any move I can
play I will go here
hmm very strong very strong mid-game I
will try to exchange Queens although
this would be a losing move g3 is bad
because he will sacrifice but if he does
then I will play King to f2 so I think
this is my only chance
but now then kid Rocko down to g2 so
can't even play that I think this is
just lost for white
well it will be if if mid K wins okay
let's see how me how mid K and this I
tried the sacrifice on f6 and well MIT
came it they played it perfectly
yes that is the the greatest move very
nice media plays it correctly and wrote
the g1 is checkmate hope media will see
it
he's taking this time so okay he will
check me first so I will play this
and it's going to each one mate very
nice meet Kay congratulations to meet
Kate everyone in the chat you must
congratulate mid Kate for this great
victory yeah there were a lot of check
me is there okay let's go a five and we
have a Kings gambit I remember playing
Knights hack yesterday so we'll go for
the phone beer counter gambit everyone
must congratulate Mike okay this is a
this is a move from a game mix against
Murphy morph it was playing black so
morphic lady 3 here so let's see if if I
can pull off the morphe game and now
give up a pawn so now I think mix put
the bishop back and d2 but we'll see how
it goes so it's a it's a very nice pawn
sacrifice by morphe and now I think it
was Bishop to d2 and after that
Bishop to g4 but we'll see okay I think
so far we do have a morphe game here but
can't really remember what more if you
played
I don't I don't want to allow him to
castle so just play Bishop to c5
like I said I only play board games in
chess comm okay I will capture here and
then here keeping his King in the center
if he captures here then well I don't
think he can pull this off maybe even
capture here I think this will be good
although this is giving up a piece but
it's allowing Quint h4 check and I don't
know kind of seems good for black but
we'll see
well there are strong players in chess
calm doesn't mean you suck but and our
friend will he will give up his night
here but I will capture here he was
probably thinking that I will capture
that I will capture with the roof so
that he can sacrifice his queen but I
think Bishop captures and details a
little better and he will give up his
queen but I don't think White has enough
compensation for this but yeah this this
e3 movement by morphe proved to be quite
useful
I don't think Bishop d3 is possible so
yeah he could play that and after
okay Tom dough let's go here so threaten
this nice check and night night night
hack resigns so we have we have a game
against nerd nervously our two thousand
rated players so let's see how near was
any place he goes Sicilian and like I
said whoever plays the Sicilian I will
play before so let's see let's see if
there was any can can beat my before
move he he is a higher rating than me so
we'll see
just go Bishop to c4 here Knight f6 okay
we'll push a five capture here
it's just Castle and put our Bishop to
b2 to protect this pawn this way as well
okay we have the knight here just bring
it back to f3 no 5 2 is too much I said
three minutes and maybe one second
increment 5 2 is too much time for other
people to wait well I enjoyed this move
very much that's pretty much the only
reason I play it
okay I think our friend there wasn't
just blundered a piece here because if
the Queen captures then well Richard 8:7
captures the Queen so unfortunate move
for nerve Azmi okay we'll just capture
the bishop here with check and play
Bishop the well this bishop should go
somewhere but I haven't decided where
probably I need to protect his bishop
from coming to g4 so I'm up a piece now
so and he plays III I don't know about
e3 seems like a pretty pretty forcing
move to play
[Applause]
now just to improve my pieces for a bit
and I think we'll be okay
probably Knight to d5 I think this ends
the game this is opening my Bishops
attacked the g7 and also if he captures
my rook will go here and I will capture
with the Queen so attacking the bishop
after Bishop e6 I'm just gonna play this
move and I think black can pretty much
resigned but I doubt that he will so
let's just play play it like this so the
Queen is the bishop is pinned and okay
he will play this
okay and any tricks up our sleeve will
he capture here you know okay I think
I'll go here if he captures the rook I
still can't play this Bishop move
because well I don't want to give up the
rooks for a queen in a winning position
but this is well at least now I think
it's it would be fair to resign although
I almost never resigned so I don't mind
playing a good game right in Nero's knee
it's too bad he blundered a piece there
and we have chicken tomatoes I think I
think chicken tomatoes also play the
game yesterday and he improved his
rating quite a lot so let's let's go
chicken tomatoes before is a bad opening
yeah
Swiper I've never played 960 in my life
and this is well this is a chest channel
so I don't think if people would be
interested in 960 chest
well okay Demetria yesterday I said if
someone will if someone wins he is
allowed to play one more game so if
you're interested in one more game I
guess I guess you could play okay what
do we have here how do we develop well I
don't want to put my Bishop on b7 to
grab ahold of this diagonal see if if it
if it can be done a ravaged ravaged
thing I am noticing you man and thank
you thank you for your nice words
okay Demetria since you won the last
game I will have to play my best this
time chill rafta chime I know this
demand and I don't really mind if you
want subscribe I'm doing the these
videos because I enjoy them and if
someone else enjoys them as well they're
welcome to watch it but threatening to
unsubscribe that's like that's not cool
man
okay so we have a this is kind of a
stone wall or well almost if I if I put
b5 and c6 but it is kind of a stone wall
setup I know you were kidding ruff ruff
- I'm just kidding you okay so he's
going for this e six pawn which is okay
I guess
why not it's undefended
we also have two notifications chest
reps and Patrick asking why I declined
his challenge well I probably defined it
because it was a the time format was too
long
[Music]
well it's not that I like dubstep it's I
can't really play any commercial music
on the stream so I have to play any free
music and this is a this is
nocopyrightsounds YouTube channel where
you know you can play all the music and
YouTube doesn't mind because if you play
any commercial music your video could be
banned in many countries okay so what
now he returns the knight to f3 and do I
play for the Stonewall no I kind of I
kind of want to play this rook here but
we'll see I'm probably going to stream
for about an hour and a half more but
maybe even two hours who knows rook to
e1 okay it's a very ungrateful position
we have to okay we'll go at h6 and then
put g5 this seems like a decent plan
frequency free songs okay I will check
it out
I'm not planning on any tournament play
machine at our okay machine or tower I
don't see a challenge from machine Oh
towel no man although I can see all the
challenges so there actually might be a
challenge from machine at our Siraj okay
see Roger I will take it into
consideration and you will be promoted
faster in the queue okay
our opponent captured here and as well
famous saying by igor Smirnoff to take
is a mistake so he who takes usually
makes the mistake so let's see how it
goes this Bishop is nice here but it's
not really doing anything this this d6
pawn is a real mountain I will capture
here although not really this Knight
doesn't have anywhere to go so I'll just
move my king from this Queens diagonal
and move my roots here aki wants to push
f3
well don't really mind that
[Music]
a Chris Richardson what is your I just
remove this for no reason
Chris Richardson I don't see you in here
Oh Moschino Tower is actually next sorry
man okay
hmm
let's get our queen into the game
prevent his queen from coming to h5 no
it's not chess comics leeches so you
know just go to leech s and challenge
away okay we don't have this rook to f3
idea although he just prevented it oh
it's a it's with increment that's why I
thought he didn't have any time left on
the clock okay
well can't really prevent him from going
for an endgame so no oh man I totally
blundered there I thought he was gonna
play something else
ah well I think I can surrender this but
like I said never surrender let's see
what our friend he manages to play yeah
of course very good chicken tomatoes big
congratulations the chicken tomatoes and
Moschino tower is gone so I'm pretty
sure he was here
shuttle began do is next ah Carl Gomez
your chicken tomatoes and this is a
correspondence game so unfortunately
chatter Bank do we will not play
correspondence and here we go it's
Moschino tower ok Demetria after machine
at our you're next
ok after someone beats my before a move
I will play something else
I'm gonna go d4
what do you mean it says you can't
challenge our motto that's funny funny
thing to say yes demetria you have
beaten before but you have to beat it
one more time
well because I enjoy playing it only the
only reason really I'm just playing this
Bishop e5 because I'm up a piece so any
piece exchange is good for me yeah it's
funny I really enjoyed the Evans gambit
in the Italian game so so this is kind
of a way of playing the Evans gambit but
in the Sicilian a lot of fun
he will probably push f5 now although I
don't recommend it really ok this is a
good move I guess and that's Queen
sacrifice right ok ok where are you meet
Kay Kay let's go meet Kate
[Music]
well yeah it is it is harder to play
while you talk in comments but it's not
that much harder although it's kind of
it's kind of hard when you look at the
chat and also the board simultaneously
well we'll see who's next in line okay
let's see Mitka Mitka has beaten my
before but can he do it twice
okay
the Evergreen game was the Evans gambit
you are right played by Adolph Anderson
it was one of the one of the most
beautiful games ever in the Evans gambit
such as such a beautiful game with the
two bishop checkmate on e7 and d7 a
spectacular game if you are referring to
that evergreen game okay how do we
punish MIT Kaye let's go Brooke the b1
attack this b7 it gets the rock out of
the way from this Bishop and also
attacks here but me to get played Bishop
to g7 right so he's not in a hurry
really well okay meet Kay she wants to
get his Kings to safety and is thinking
about sacrificing a few pawns while
doing so okay but this is well not good
for meet K I would say he is attacking
two of my pieces but he forgot about the
c7 point I think so that's unfortunate
for him so we can capture with the rook
which is fine I think
since the knight is pinned and the King
can't capture so going to f8 would be
quite troublesome rough edge I can't
accept your challenge before I accept
all the other challenges you know
wouldn't be fair to other people just
capture this Knight here maybe although
although
it's not all that all that
straightforward how to win this I will
capture here so if he captures the
bishop I will sacrifice these two pieces
to get my rook to be seven and he
captures here I kind of didn't think he
would do that but okay so what's good to
be seven quite an interesting position
and the muscle very low on time so meat
cake could could win this actually I
have to be very careful
hmm and he captures here okay so if I
move my knight he will capture here
I do want to play this move for some
reason I am allowing yes he will capture
but I will not capture back just yet
first I will check him now I will
capture here and how are we doing he's
actually doing pretty good have to make
some room for our King I do have this
pawn which is nice for me
and on downtime we have to play this a
bit faster probably with 95 and now
Knight to b5 have to use my queen
effectively
[Music]
he has this bishop check okay and he can
capture here but this loses a rook
actually
[Music]
very nice meat give very nice game it
was a it was a very nice game somehow my
before managed to prevail okay we have
problems next okay I don't know if
Pavlov's is in the stream meat K Mitka
is becoming quite the player
it seems everyone will play the Sicilian
now just for me to play before I don't
mind I enjoyed this very much
[Music]
we'll just play h3 with an idea let's
see if if Palace is interested in this
idea he's actually not interested in
this idea I'm well I'm very satisfied
with his choice of playing e6 quite a
nice move although this is losing a
piece for me I just realized if he
captures an item a knight on f3 but okay
I do have some threats on b7 so it's
hard to say
and he goes upward with the s-bahn
larvae what do you mean you're waiting
for an hour the challenges are going
chronologically and by the way what is
your nickname unleashes larvae because
see four here
how can he lose to Croat huh that's
that's a lousy thing to say man larvae
ok larvae I'm I'm looking at all the
challenges and there is no challenge
from larvae so are you sure you're
challenging me well just go to each s
and challenge me
[Music]
yeah it's it's it's very hard to play
with if I have to answer all these
questions but yeah so he's attacking
this phone he wants to capture our place
e4 since his King distill in the middle
I don't want to open the position
somehow and this pawn on e6 is pretty
weak so I will try to go for it if he
doesn't react to the c-4 move yeah I
will go c5 and try to go for this pawn
now although it's hard to unpin I have
to figure out how to unpin and he will
sacrifice here okay I don't think it's a
very good move but maybe maybe sometimes
activity is better than just you know
okay what's this doing not much I think
so let's just go for this a six bone
[Music]
well I learned to play chess when I was
five but I never really played it until
I was maybe 18 a fistfight I'm not much
of a fist fighter brazuca and he plays
Bishop d7 and now I'm finally unpinned
so let's go let's attack this rook first
and then maybe put the night here and
attack this e 6 pawn one more time
rook c1 also seems interesting to maybe
get a hold of this C file first just
grab this pawn here what am I missing
here what is this what kind of moves are
these ah keys he's very low on time so
he tried to make something happen okay
next is basic a bit will play two
follows as well well it's just that
other players challenged before you so
it's nothing really I can do the
challenges in the top are the last so if
you challenged me well the challenges in
the top are chronologically why should
play next on the meta just came here
and they sure Kaiba is well not playing
so we will abort the game maybe he left
or something and we have rocked Brazil
with better Aris next in line blas
browser with a 3-minute game
yeah met at the legend he was sleeping
there for for an hour and now he he came
to sleep over here another Sicilian so I
guess I have to play before there's
really no other choice for me
let's try Bishop to b2 I have a
challenge from McDowell probably wanted
to ride Michael Tao but it was taken
[Music]
now I play Bishop c4 and blunder this
this nice efore pawn
so although brazo isn't interested in
this pawn so let's just push it probably
Knight to c6 or simply castling would be
fine
for black
[Music]
okay let's castle as well
always bring your King to safety if if
the opportunity is right okay I have to
get some development in they should to
be seven probably it's a nice move it's
a very nice move and I will move my
queen from here so after he captures I
will capture with the Queen I don't
really mind him capturing an f3 with his
bishop that's a very strong Bishop I
would I would be glad if he took it okay
now we will capture and play Bishop to
d3 black is the black is okay here black
is more than okay here
what do you mean eight-second increment
man
ah it's John Bartholomew not the real
John Bartholomew but it's a very nice to
have John Bartholomew in my chat even if
it's not the real one it's a it's a
great honor
ok I have to be I have to be careful of
this move and this threat of checkmate
and g2 so I just want to exchange this
knife here because this bishop is very
strong so I'm hoping to challenge it
something some some way and the brass
ooh of course isn't interested in this
and why would he be
so he does have this Knight to c3 move
I'm just gonna play f4 okay so f5 is
good but now this e six phone is well
terrible yeah I know you're gonna play
that just have to capture probably with
the rook although this Bishop is doing a
nice job protecting everything he'll
capture with the pawn okay he does want
to this is a nice move because if he
protects the e6 pawn
oh it's with check well that's a that's
a terrible blunder but this this bishop
is a week I think probably will be able
to capture on f5 if you protect c6
somehow and as well he does so let's
just capture here so if he captures this
e seven Bishop will fall and if he
doesn't well I think he has to
Kelly just captured this guy now Bishop
takes on f7 is also a threat but okay
how do we play this
hmm I'll just try it like this I'm
getting low on time so although I do
like my position haha he's gonna play
this so if he captures with the rook I
will capture capture and then capture
here it's not going to work so I have to
play I have to play this first and also
guard this somehow oh man I accidentally
pressed a rematch man I need more coffee
this is I missed the mate in 1 and G 2
so definitely need more coffee ok we
have to play faster this one cuz it's a
bullet game yeah I missed the mate in
one so very hard to play so much chess I
hope it was a one-time thing
hope I don't make her more blunders like
this
so go see four he could have captured
here actually some nice move
you missed this unfortunately maybe I
should have captured Baruch but I
decided not to because I think I can
protect it with Bishop to f3 also
threatening this so it's quite
unfortunate
oh I didn't even see and make a move
oh it's always always nice to play a
bullet well I don't know I don't even
see all the challenges but there are a
lot that may be so brazuca but still
it's not an excuse for missing a meeting
one larvae yeah I still don't have a
challenge from you so we have our seek
crawler I will capture here and maybe
mm-hmm so nice nice pin what made me
play chess well it's a funny story
actually
I was a disco playground one day and a
friend of mine said that he can beat me
in a game of chess in seven moves and
although I only knew just the rules I I
was pretty sure that he couldn't beat me
in seven weeks and well what happened
was actually that another lead if he
didn't beat me in seven moves but I beat
him and that's kind of how I started
playing so what do we have here well
this Bishop is very annoying so I
definitely want to remove him from here
I'm not too happy about giving up my
bishop but it was really the only way to
do so
[Music]
okay this is giving up a phone I think
so I have to be careful I don't want to
miss another mate in one okay so this is
attacking a lot a lot of things here
not really I'm just gonna kick the Queen
away I'm gonna guard my pawns and maybe
exchange a queen and enjoy my pawn up so
let's just capture here and this I think
will do fine if he moves the knight I
will push c5 and try to protect this
phone and he will move it what's the
threat here I wrote the c1 and the night
to it - okay it's a nice threat I will
give him that
so I'll just play like this I think so
this check isn't isn't as good I have no
idea why you can't challenge me maybe
you're doing something wrong in the
settings Lucas :
[Music]
larvae I'm extremely sorry but there is
no larvae in the challenges okay III
don't really understand this move giving
up a piece like that but I will give the
piece back so that's how I decided to
play this because I don't really need
the piece the spawns are very strong
probably a lot stronger than that night
was
well the players are selected you
challenge me and then when it's your
turn chronologically you get to play a
game but okay I will I will accept
someone who is okay ravaged someone who
hasn't played yet so I'm pretty sure
you're doing something wrong with these
challenges but okay rough - it's your
turn to play
I've been sitting for a bit long and but
it's a correspondence game ravaged I
can't play a correspondence game when so
many people are in the okay who do we
have who hasn't played okay Sierra
chakra I mean I did accept your
challenge over the line but since I have
seen you in the chat for the previous
hour and something so okay okay let's go
if five maybe some more interesting
games yeah that night was quite a
blunder so we'll go for the Russian and
if he accepts maybe play some nice
Russian gambit yes rough dish
this is the elite chess
King crusher is online I would challenge
King crusher but King crusher doesn't
accept challenges
hi throw this Apple good to see you man
do I want to allow Bishop to g5 I don't
really mind and he goes for it I'm not
gonna play eight six because I don't
really think it's necessary so I'm gonna
pin his knight as well it's a pretty
equal position pretty proportional setup
Larbi gaming I can't send you a
challenge because then I would lose all
of these well but you can tell me since
your username is the lobby gaming
what are you gaming you have some gaming
videos on your channel
yes Vishal of course you can play the
where is your challenge I don't have
your challenge but it says your offline
I think that's why your challenge went
to the bottom and what's so funny about
the question what are you gaming
okay let's just play 94 pin this night
so I think g4 has to be played here to
prevent any kind of fast fast deciding
moves okay me Sarah you are next
but mister please challenge to a three
minute game not a five minute game I
will not accept five minute games since
there are too many people and what do we
have here
just play c6 not sure what the night is
gonna do here
this H bone is very weak so let's just
attack
okay Vishal is next our 2200 rated
friend so I think it was a mistake to
give up this h2 reborn no we'll just
play this allow this Bishop to capture
here but then I can push d3 maybe I
think I think Siraj chakra has two too
little time on its clock so that's quite
unfortunate
okay Vishal okay let's go a rap teacher
because you challenged me to a
correspondence game with no toilet time
limit you have to challenge to a
3-minute game or less but if you
challenge again I will play you since
you messed up your challenge okay so
let's see and we have this Bishop to g5
move again a very nice move indeed kind
of prevents me from playing Bishop to b4
it's just Castle here you will probably
go for the queenside castle so I will
just expand
okay
I do kind of like this but to do I want
my wish bunny 7 I don't think so
although let's see what it does he can't
really threaten anything with 95 we're
going to D here so let's just play a six
maybe now let's play let's play D six
if he captures here I can't really take
back with the deep on because I will
lose my queen after this move although
although this could be winning as well
but I don't think it is because I will
get a tempo after 95 Bishop captures on
g5 would check he will capture with
Czech King to g8 and then Queen to h5 is
probably winning so I think I will just
have to ignore him for the time being
and play King to each eight it's a very
nice idea indeed
I mean think I have to play the g6 here
although although white has a great
attack here I really like White's attack
but this kind of prevents him from
playing h5 for the moment so I will try
to hold this but it will be very hard
white has a very nice attack here and he
is preparing to go g5 I like this very
much
I mean h5 if he plays h5 he's he's very
good I think his position is quite
winning I haven't played this oh I
thought I did hmm and he does play it so
I will just capture here now H takes g5
would be a mistake because it would
allow this I have to play g5 now
unfortunately perhaps I can now capture
the bishop yes I can but I don't think
it will do me that much good
I will go here
and try to play rook to b8 maybe he
threatens he threatens all sorts of
things can't really allow this
oh very nice checkmate very nice by
Vishal I thought I had him there very
nice game Vishal okay we have Stefan
name Anya bored ecstasy room huh
very nice very nice checkmate I I had a
lot I I didn't really have a lot of time
on the clock so I didn't really have got
the time to calculate the the variation
but so that's another good thing to know
you have to you have to be careful of
your time on the clock but a very nice
game very nice play and a very nice
attack I defended as much as I could but
okay erupted let me check if you
challenged me I don't have a challenge
from your raft edge just go h3 this Punk
can't really be captured because Roewe
because of rookie one I don't have a
challenge from your raft edge
so this f6 move isn't really
accomplishing much here so if we shall
wants to play another game of course we
can play and the Neyman yacht is trying
to escape I like this
nemanja I can't let you escape
well I knew I know Bishop captures an 87
was good and that the bishop cannot be
captured but like I said I tried to
defend it but it was it was simply too
hard a rock edge what did you see in the
video I'm not sure I know what you're
talking about
okay mr. I if you challenged to a
shorter time format then we can play yes
this is a I'll play Knight to b5 this
seems like an okay move ok rough days I
will check after this game yeah I'm
pretty sure I was winning but didn't do
me any good ok after a kink the b6 maybe
Bishop to e3
oh he's gonna play this ok I'm just
gonna go for this Queen to f7 check now
we go here should be enough to win this
Kaylah I'm gonna sacrifice my queen
because I think well I kind of think
this is winning and he doesn't even want
to accept my queen
it's not cool man you should always
accept the Queen sacrifice if your
opponent sacrifices of Queen well yeah
so of course you need to sign in it's
the point
[Music]
nemanja says what a slaughter yeah it is
kind of a slaughter but you helped a lot
so I didn't I didn't really do all that
much you just allowed one check okay me
Sarah let's see if Mitra finally
challenged to a three minute game a raft
edge I see your challenge but you
challenged me to a two-day game you have
to challenge me to 3 minutes or less
okay misra
okay c5 like I said we're gonna go
before see how mistre handles this
before idea
well sure Daniel if you challenge then
you're next in line of course you can
play when the rating has a question mark
it means that the user has just created
to their account and well he has to play
I think ten games to get his rating so
he hasn't played ten games yet only
chess to get the official rating ok
Ratish I'm checking your challenge your
challenge is here and it's a it's a
trimming a game but you put it 8 second
increments so I don't know if I'm not
being clear or something
so please challenge to an a lower time
format three minutes is okay but not a
not an eight second increment
and I do I do think that leaches is
messing this up somehow
okay v6 seems like an interesting idea
although I'm not gonna play it just yet
if he captures with the Queen I don't
really have a follow-up so okay I kind
of like my expansion here how do we play
this I would like to play a four but
it's it's really not he's gonna go
Bishop to b7 yeah I'm gonna go d3 and
then move my bishop to c1 and go go here
because it's really not doing anything
can be 2 anymore so on h6 I'm gonna go
Queen to f3 okay this is all very good
okay now stage I will check it one more
time but if it's a some kind of a weird
time format then I really don't know
what to say anymore okay I think f4 is
available now
finally choose genius wizard okay Lucas
:
I will I will check it out after this
game what did you change that the the
challenge is going through now
[Music]
okay so can the Queen capture this it's
a it's an interesting move ah it's Czech
and my knight is hanging okay
but his knight is hanging as well so I'm
not sure about this
Queen to d4 move okay we shall you are
first since you you want the game but I
will have Lucas before your game ah so
first capture this attack this okay I
see it
very nice very nice indeed I did see
your challenge McDowell I said it was a
probably probably me hotel was taken so
you had to change it to McDowell okay me
Sarah
well like I said I don't have any more
coffee so or do I capture with the
bishop is my bishop doing anything on c4
I don't think it is I'm gonna capture
with the bishop and go Knight f4 our
next move if I go here he will capture
here so not a great idea for me so I'm
just gonna go Queen here I don't know it
either either my opponents are getting
stronger and stronger or I'm simply
playing too much okay I don't really
care about this so let's go for that
Knight to e4 move
if he captures I will capture with the
pawn of course not with the rook so he
will go probably rook to a2 and this is
a nice position for black I would say
I do have to protect it okay so we're
both down to one minute so I guess this
is a bullet game now
although misra is spending a lot of time
since he has less than 30 seconds
allowing me to play this night to h5
which is pretty dangerous since well I
will capture with the Queen here and now
after this check I will capture the rook
so it's quite unfortunate for him
okay we have a resignation and
okay since we said we shall won a game
so we shall get the chance for a rematch
and let's see how a 2202 challenges
might be four so now pay attention
because he will probably do a very nice
job
into in challenging it
yes well I also said that visual gets a
chance for a rematch because you want a
game and he also waited for a while but
you are next and then Cohen if I see
Cohen in the challenges although I
didn't see it what is your nickname
Cohen and mr. nude is here again he was
also a part of the stream yesterday okay
so let's see I think he has to capture
this yeah but it's probably the only way
I can develop
let's go Bishop to e2 and prepare to
push
you'll probably castle now and now we'll
go f4 to try and get the something here
and I probably want my rook and c1 now
I will threaten this a74 Thank You
Ciotti Metta thank you very much well
any rating is good if you enjoy playing
chess of course
why is he allowing me to take care it's
a very strange thing to do a very
strange thing to do indeed can he trap
my queen
well let's see he will try to trap it ah
he will capture this one okay I like it
Bishop to c5 okay
he'll probably capture here now but I
don't know that this D pawn is looking
pretty strong wow you played so many
GM's thilo very nice
where did you play against Peter Svidler
and we have this Bishop to d4 move I
really like this move after I play this
he will probably capture here but this
this allows me to push ok I see what he
did there I will play here since he
doesn't have a LightSquared bishop
although other moves are probably just
as good so what what did we get here
nothing much I think I think I will have
to give up my rope here but I don't mind
I really like this pawn seems like a
very strong bond
okay I will give up this bishop as well
although that might be a bit too much
well I do prefer leeches for a number of
reasons I'm gonna try it he's gonna put
b5 so maybe this wasn't such a good move
so okay
we'll go Quinn to e6 so maybe get some
counter play here and unless he goes
team to h6 I think I'm gonna have to
settle for a draw here because roofed f7
I think is losing and also King yeah
okay he's gonna try King at age six but
I don't think it's possible to play this
unfortunately
and this is this is quite bad for him I
think
he didn't want to draw so now he will
try to win or lose it doesn't really
matter for him so unfortunately that it
that is checkmate okay let's see Raj
where are you Raj where are you I don't
see Raj okay but mcdowell okay you're
next Nick tile so I guess I guess you're
you're a fan of Michael tell like myself
so let's see how McDowell plays this
rocket there is no challenge of yours
here I'm checking all the challenges as
you can see your challenge isn't here
okay McDowell plays d4 I'm gonna go d5
maybe make it a more interesting game
yeah he's going for the London system
everybody is playing the London system
so I guess it's okay let's see how
McDowell plays it if he allows me I will
push this since I don't really have a
plan for this LightSquared Bishop he's
gonna go Knight to f3 I'm gonna go back
and he's not gonna go Knight to f3
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna play four
tricks if he doesn't want to play this
now I will play this f5 move Knight to
e5 doesn't seem all that scary I will
simply retreat my queen if he plays it
but I definitely would like to play a
four since neither over rooks are really
doing anything he's gonna go at for now
but no he's not actually okay it's a
nice move so nice move and saying that
my f5 was was not a good move so how do
we develop the LightSquared bishop hmm
let's just do a rock lift
Boris vascular Fischer well I think
history showed us who's better Spassky
or Fischer let's just go here since he
doesn't have a dark square bishop and
he's really changing all of these pieces
mm-hmm I don't know I think this is
quite good for me now since it's not
easy to defend this h3 point he would
have to play King 2h do
well tips for people started starting to
play chess will study the endgame
definitely you know even if you don't
get a great advantage in the opening or
you know you you play not such a good
middle game it's always the endgame that
matters and then later when you'll be
tactically strong and have a good
opening repertoire then you can try and
finish games in the middle game this is
very hard okay we have let's see who we
have next
it's crazy Butler I know he's been
waiting also for for a long time Paul I
don't have a towel stare it's impossible
to go to do at all stare it said it's
it's an interesting idea Dmitry
switching it into a groom field system
defense and I I don't think crazy Butler
is here because well when the circle is
gray its it means he's not online okay
we have Russian next
Larbi your name is lobby below okay
let's see if we have a challenge from
larva but as you can see there is no
challenge from such a username okay
let's go for a stone wall
yeah it's if you say Ella kynar almost
any player it's always Alec I'm will
accept kappa blanka of course
do I want to capture here I kind of do
so now now if f3 and I don't want to
exchange this Bishop because well mine
isn't really doing anything just gonna
capture with the C pawn and make maybe
Bishop to d7 he doesn't want to exchange
it okay I will play Bishop to d7 and now
rook the c8
I will go here and now play Bishop to b5
I don't want to exchange this
LightSquared bishop because my
LightSquared bishop is garbage kid it's
an interesting plan I'm gonna try rook
c8 and then put another rockin c8 Rock
c6 and then other rock and see it seems
like a decent plan although although my
opponent will not allow it I guess he
just has to go back now now I will
double up on this e-file
well guys I see everyone's challenged
but there are a lot of people
challenging and I know you're waiting
for a long time but it's really not that
long
we're playing three-minute games so
that's maybe a six minute per game so
ten players is 16 minutes that's like an
hour if you're eleventh in line then
it's natural you'll have to wait for
more than an hour okay I will capture
here and this is a well I will try to
capture this does seem like an
interesting idea would you check and now
check back to here and now I will push
so this is probably winning for me
although Russia played a very good game
I always enjoy playing the stone wall so
now he plays this okay I will definitely
capture here or do I push capture or
push well better capture if you can I
guess also attacking this Bishop and he
will allow me to capture it so I guess
I'll capture it and play this move next
and he resigns so okay this is an
unlimited time so will refuse and next
in line is soaring soaring then Petra
Juarez Lobby there is there's a there's
a hundred people in the chat I'm really
trying to answer everyone but I also do
have to play you are noticed Oreo okay
let's play f4 kind of a Kings gambit I
checked challenges just now and there is
no nice use of Ella kinds gun there yeah
that definitely was an Ella kinds guns a
rock rock queen battery well I see 97
but okay if you want to be nitpicking
do I capture here or do I play at five I
capture and I kind of do want to castle
but can't really castle at the moment
soaring is a very strong player Sauron
is really playing fast and good moves I
will have to really be careful this game
I think so if I was okay I will play
Knight c4 so if he captures this pawn
will become weak but definitely I will
have to play King to h1 and although b5
might be an idea
Vishal what do you mean by the other
game and he will take this okay
interesting interesting plan well king
each one would be kind of a mistake here
but I don't really see my options he's
playing a very nice game if I play Queen
to d3 than d5 probably is coming it's
not not an easy position for me
definitely
so instead I will play rook to e1 not
Queen to d3 video games or sports well I
was a I was a very you know active
player of League of Legends for a while
I did get I think to the promotions for
platinum okay I can play this and after
capturing I do have to protect it
somehow I think it doesn't matter but
I'm pretty sure if Ella kind guy Ella
kinds gun is used it will be used
vertically okay we had a we had this
night move okay
seems like a good move but level okay I
thought he played
I do have to get my he's gonna play
Queen to h6
and I don't want to allow night to g3 so
what are my options my options is
playing b3 and hope he doesn't get get
this Bishop to a3 move although I think
I still think Soren is better here
it's kind of hard because I play without
my ear pieces and well I don't I don't
hear the the sound of the moves and
that's quite a disorienting I really
like to hear the sound of the moves when
I play so it's C 5 now actually even
possible
Bishop to a3 he will play C 5 of course
and now he will play this okay with the
idea of 93 so if I capture the night on
g3 I think I should be okay now
I don't want to allow my g3 but if you
place it I'm not going to capture anyway
so I'm really looking forward to
capturing this night with my rook that
would give me a good game
yeah that's that's a good point Lucas
yeah he did play the snide g3 move
although I'm not one one bit interested
in in capturing that so I'm just gonna
play anything else it's gonna go here
I'm just gonna push my pawns
yeah a very nice game by soren and we
have a Petrobras with a bullet game
again I don't know there are 15 that I
can see
well we're spending too much time since
it's a bullet game shouldn't really
waste all that time so it's a bullet
game I can't really afford any time in
talking I have to get in bullet mode not
the same explaining a three minute game
mmm I will capture this and go c4 she
captures this I will do this okay
I think rook here is good
and we have a passed pawn that's really
nice to have in Bullitt although I don't
like this diagonal being open so I will
play g3 and now i blundered this h3 pawn
which he captures of course immediately
but I don't really mind what's important
is that the dark square diagonal isn't
open so this is winning I think because
now this b7 pawn is well I don't really
get this move it's a very strange move
to play
okay and it's meet K again and K but Ron
next well I actually Demetri I honest I
uninstalled League of Legends in season
six because well whenever I feel that
played ranked I could well easily beat
platinum players if I played my Katarina
but after they reworked it I simply
can't play anymore I mean I play all the
players but for a really important game
always played Katarina well he didn't
really blunder but well he did use too
much time in a critical position yes
mister I see it but I I mean you have to
wait in line like everyone else I can't
really accept it unless you win a game
like Vishal has yeah Katrina probably is
overpowered but I simply refuse to spend
all this time you know learning it and
well it's probably better to play chess
than League of Legends anyway
okay I really don't like my position
here so it's very passive Mitka is
standing like a boss
so I have to have to do something about
this how do I break open the position in
any move b5 probably is coming okay I
will take I will accept this just to get
some sort of play you think he didn't
see okay okay at least that at least I
got some play on the queenside so maybe
but not really I have to play the rook
back here now I love rock day 7 it's
very annoying although he doesn't play
it so I'm kind of happy about that it's
a very hard position to play meet Kate
Kate did a great job although he is
allowing me this move so I did get some
comfortably here at least
yeah I wasn't actually going for a for a
passive game it just happened oh it's
two and a half hours already actually I
will play this - maybe harass his queen
a bit he doesn't allow it of course
still there are very few moves for me to
play I could probably I don't know it's
a terrible position for me
I'll finish Queen I mean the knight me
get playing like a boss again there's no
stopping this guy quite a move so okay I
will capture the pawn so but that allows
him to capture this other rook if I
capture okay I will capture it let's see
what media plays so he will probably
capture the rook here but if he doesn't
so all this all quite the same at least
I got out I got a pawn from that little
skirmish but now rook the b1 is looking
really good although he doesn't play it
she doesn't play it
I have to capture now play this passive
move
very active play by MIT gay
I will have to make some room for my
king of course since the bishops can't
really penetrate this he wants to go
here I'm not gonna allow that she wants
to take my night on f8 but I can't
really stop it either so unfortunately
this is what I have to play and he will
attack it this way
interesting interesting
play by MIT Kay and he plays this okay
we'll see how it goes
have to pin the bishop now make some
room for my own king here although I
didn't do it correctly really
and all in all it was a bullet game in
the end but a great game by mid kay
okay ruff - now I see our challenge you
are next after this game roughage and
after all this waiting I am sure it will
be a great game so Kaiba tron was a very
active player yesterday and he kept
improving with every game let's see how
he does
good game Dimitri so maybe maybe maybe
we even hit 100 people I've never had
100 people in the stream so a lot of
people enjoy chess in the morning yes
Lucas although Kaiba Tron isn't playing
so okay ruff - lets go
yeah that's a that's a good one everyone
invite your friends even if they don't
like chess if if such people exist yes
Lucas it's you have to raft raft edge
it's definitely you what do you mean by
raft edge is new I was going to put my
stream on Twitter but I forgot someone
asked me to play a bullet game and well
after playing the bullet game I just
started streaming cam just gonna get my
phone back although this does allow b4
but enough - chose not to play before so
we'll just stop it with a five and we'll
go P six and D five
if raffish allows it he plays very fast
well doesn't really I don't think this
move order has a name it's some
something of a groom Phil but not really
okay so Bishop to b3 I think I'm gonna
capture the bishop although might not be
the greatest the greatest of plans and
now play Knight here
I did capture the bishop what do you
mean
yeah Oreo Oreos correct that wasn't a
free piece if it was a free free piece I
would definitely take a free piece ok so
rough ditch is not at all a bad player
well play a four just to dislocate his
knight from this c3 square and if he
plays Knight captures then well we'll
just see what happens
I think Queen to a5 would the attack on
this rook would be nice but we have to
get rid of this Knight first that's
moving our Queen away from this rook and
now now we play something something nice
well depends on what rafters plays
and roughage decided to give up his
night so I will I will capture it deep
sack is the type of sauce yeah of course
it is it's a type of source you used to
use for Pringles dip I will play Queen
to a5 once again just to I this rook
yeah second the king is always a great
idea okay so now this rook - okay now
this was a free piece so a very nice
game by ravage but a couple of more
precise moves would have probably held
the game I just go back to g7
okay since I'll be streaming for I don't
know how long I will accept Cohen's
challenge and then I will accept
challenge challenges from people who
haven't yet played so let's go Bishop to
d7 just you know to give everyone a
chance
okay so capturing here probably well
okay but he doesn't really have any time
left
okay Cohen I don't really see your
challenger but I do see la brie okay la
brie let's go
good luck as well lovely let's go me
five yeah
well Phil oh it was it wasn't really a
fully open position so maybe Knights
could have done something there but it
yeah it was definitely too early to give
up the knights the bishops for the
Knights in my opinion and we have a we
have a d5 game here so this should be
interesting
see how how lot replace this not going
for the main line with Bishop to b5 but
rather going for this Bishop to b3 I
haven't seen this move so far so it
should be interesting Lucas I was going
to play but I don't see our challenge
you should make our challenge I mean
your username unleashes the same as a
new tube so I know who I'm playing
yeah you're welcome library okay so
playing Knight to d4
because now the knight was threatened so
I'm just gonna castle here man I should
really do some stretching I've been
sitting for so long just genius wizard
okay okay just genius wizard you're you
are next since I haven't played you yet
okay his King is still in the center can
we take advantage of this I will play
Bishop to c5 because this Knight no
longer can retreat to b3 since the
bishop is on b3 so let's see how that
goes
it's uh I don't really see a good place
for the night if he goes to b5 I will
just play a six a six and kick the
knight back to a3 and in this position
well probably Bishop to g4 with the
tempo is okay not a lot of moves for
this White Queen she has to go to f1 f3
is not a good move so if she goes to f1
well then the King stays in the center
and then we can play
your sorrow is still asleep although I
do see him online playing he's probably
playing from his bed
yeah b5 is good but the king is still in
the center so breaking open the position
is more important so this rook to e8
move is well quite deadly because now
this Knight can't be captured since well
this bishop is spinning the Queen so not
a lot of moves for white here and he
does capture out she wants to take back
okay
I will capture this a rafted notice the
message I am noticing it I'm just not
seeing what to notice catches genius
let's go finally against Lucas Cohen if
that is your real name
oh well it's it's allowed since it
wasn't a very you know it was a pretty
bad move so if you're referring to the
take back Marvel or six-six next please
okay Marvel oh yeah Lee chess allows
take backs and it's it's an okay feature
I guess if you know especially if you
play a longer game and then you make a
really stupid move okay so a chess
genius wizard accepts my challenge to go
into the Russian gambit and we'll see
we'll see how it turns out
just play this move and well I will
sacrifice here just for the fun of it
[Music]
it's kind of the whole point of playing
the Russian gambit if if white allows it
black will get some play although I
think white is better here but he has to
play precise moves and well this wasn't
a very precise move so some unfortunate
for for Lucas Cohen yell Arbit it was a
nice game as well and this is well
unfortunately checkmate came Marvel oh
you're next
since I said that before I start playing
anyone I will play only people who
haven't yet played
videos I have played on ICC but I don't
anymore I don't know I I don't really
remember what is the reason
that's internet Chess Club right that's
not chess cube or something
okay let's see how Marvel plays against
my before in the Scandinavian he will
accept it of course I like it that he
accepts it okay no nice to be five could
be quite annoying but I will consider it
especially now since it does take away
quite a few decent squares for the Queen
and maybe next move go Bishop to b2 but
then Bishop to e7 I think solves
everything
for black so I haven't really justified
my pawn sacrifice yet or I don't know if
I ever will but playing playing d4 and
Bishop to f4 with the threatened c7
could be kind of interesting if he
doesn't play a6 if you plays a six then
well then I guess always wall for black
you just downloaded
leeches that's full of ads ICC is full
of ads
he plays 94 well that certainly isn't a
move I would expect but I'm sure he has
his reasons probably to go night here
okay everyone who hasn't played so far
killing satra will just just go on
leeches org and challenge my name it's
here
I got motto you can see it right here
and yeah I like this move Bishop to d6
although now now I do have a bishop and
I do like my bishop so I think my two
bishops are stronger here it's a 3d open
game
we have castles and now well let's just
play c3 first to protect this pawn and
then maybe maybe make some threats he
can't really develop the bishop on d7
since although he can I don't I don't
think I will capture here it's a very
nice move this Knight is undefended but
can I do something about it if he plays
h6 if he does play h6 which could be a
good move I will not play queen g4 Queen
g4 with the threat of Bishop h6 but this
yeah I kind of miss the c5 move it's
interesting to see though if he 5 is
good
I could even sacrifice this bishop
because well yeah that that's an okay
move I guess but like I said like I said
I will play Queen to f3 and I will
capture here so Bishop to b7 is a is
pretty attractive he's gonna go Bishop
to e6 I like this even better and if he
goes f5 if he goes f5 my knight will be
trapped so I definitely don't want to do
that I have to play this although this
kind of traps my queen hmm should really
watch my moves but he doesn't have a lot
of time so he's playing really fast so
maybe now f5 no okay miss the Greek gift
earlier could be could be I really don't
like this Bishop here so let's just kick
it not a lot of places for him to go to
okay who haven't we played so far Miguel
Gomez we haven't played Miguel Gomez and
next is della say I'm sorry if I miss
the pronoun I mispronounced some of your
names
no Marvolo it was a it was a good game
yeah it kind of looks like daya say I
don't know Demetria but first I'm gonna
play people who haven't yet played I
don't think that there are maybe three
or four of them and of vanuatu on yes
Vanuatu as well well : also was unable
to challenge me so maybe he can explain
it to you Bishop e7 okay I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go D 3 and a 3 just to keep
this Bishop safe and then I I'll see
what I what I would like to play next so
yeah if he plays d6 and Bishop to e6 I
will capture it because I I don't mind
the exchanging it for another Bishop but
I really don't like it changing my life
square bishop for a knight so this is c6
is preparing d5 but this kind of drops a
pawn here so maybe d6 was better
Magnus well no now Magnus didn't inspire
me to play the Italian I was inspired to
play the Italian by by Croatian player I
saw a nice game played by him a tweet
two years ago and then I said me okay
maybe the Italian is okay to play but
mostly I played the Italian because I
look forward to playing the Evans gambit
if my opponent plays Bishop to c5 so
that's that's probably the reason why I
like the Italian killing well you should
ask Colin Colin had this problem and he
solved it Cohen Lucas :
and the Miguel Gomez is under one minute
so okay the rook is moved from f8 so now
this f7 pawn is weak this Bishop will
come in very handy let's just see how to
how to attack it
well if you enjoy playing blitz or
bullet yeah
the NZ ambit is definitely the thing to
look up Bishop to c5 and now we'll play
h3 just not to allow any Bishop to g4
ideas or capturing the night here
[Music]
hello yes'm name-o unnameable steady
managed to zero either ah that's my dad
he brought something for me so I told
him I couldn't go down to get it so he
will bring it up here oh well the time
control kind of depends on which opening
you're going to play because well if you
don't have a lot of time well you're not
gonna play a very risky or risky opening
like the Evans gambit I mean it unless
you know it really well okay so this is
a well Gomez doesn't really have a lot
of time so let's just capture here so
very hard for him to play this it's only
a temporary Queen sacrifice
Vishal yes but only after I play all the
other players who are waiting in queue
so we have okay della say they'll say is
next yeah good game rook captures on a6
if that is what that means okay della
say it's your turn
okay we have d4 so let's go Knight to f6
let's go for the benoni if del Este will
allow it of course I do enjoy our games
visual since you're a very good player
but I have to give other people the
opportunity to play as well
so I'm going for this set up with E 5
not woody 6 kind of a I think it's a
it's check benoni and lately I've been
preferring it to the regular Benoni
especially if white plays this Bishop to
8 6 move which seems good but actually
it's not really accomplishing that much
for white because this Knight is
excellent on g7 and the white doesn't
really want to exchange it and it's
it'll be pretty hard for black to do
anything with this Bishop now so I might
even I might even play but no I don't
want to do that okay but I will my dark
square Bishop isn't really doing
anything
thank you videos for for using the Bell
button and he captures the night which i
think is a good move this night would be
deadlier than this bishop but your user
name is seems quite familiar videos it
sounds like this video creation software
or something okay so that was safe has
more time than me and we have to we have
to do something about this and I don't
really like my bishop in g5 Plus this
deep one is looking very dangerous I
think I'm gonna go to Queen to h4 and
then well Knight to g3 seems like an
idea but not really I will play it then
we'll see how it goes
so Queen tell you one seems like a good
response yeah quickly one is a very nice
response I'm gonna try and play my
bishop h4 so let's let's see okay so
this pawn is attacked here I'm just
going to defend it for for the moment
and now go Bishop to h4
so a very nice idea he's attacking it
twice if I allow him to capture it okay
I will allow him to capture it and then
play Queen to g5 synchronize for movie a
stupid at the pollen poppy
okay so he decided to give up her his
rook which i think which i think is an
okay move i will play this Knight to g3
because if he captures it then this
night will fall although i don't think
he will capture it his position is good
without actually capturing this cake he
plays Bishop here and now I'll try
another interesting idea but not yet
first they have to develop this Bishop
definitely
and we are entering bullet area so
actually like his position although
capturing on f1 and Bishop to b5 would
have been better this is allowing him to
create a path bone here which is
excellent quite excellent I do have to
capture I don't really have any other
options
I'm gonna have to try some tricks here
although his night is so good and b6
it's not gonna be easy
his night is actually excellent on v6
okay I'm gonna go for this move and now
I think I think I'm actually winning
here but we'll see I kind of think this
is winning yeah
it was a good game day let's say
probably one of the one of the toughest
I had so far
well again against vishal of course it
was a bit harder okay we have who is
next we have we have played these guys
and trotted sample I haven't played you
try to sample okay but one watt on is
first
and it's a it's a d4 from when watan so
I'm gonna go for the knight f6 c5 yeah I
think it was a good game
okay that's I I enjoy developing my
bishop this way
I'll just go b6 and I think Bishop to a6
would be okay
making Sun I don't really okay I will
capture it but probably I had I had a
better move but I just want to push here
so I don't really mind his rook on f1 I
would mind if his rook was an h1 but
this kind of allows me well okay I think
this is not a good move but we'll just
have to see because if he captures here
then
Queen Queen to h1 is checkmate
so okay but he did find a solution to
this
so how do we continue
well any move is good I guess
because he can't dump in from this I
will capture the Queen with Czech ruler
opus is here and yeah unfortunately he's
gonna go for the a6 pawn but do I mind
do I might do I mind this well not
really
I'm gonna let him have it since now rope
today it would be quite deadly okay he's
gonna go here not really interested in
that I'm just gonna kick it kick it away
from there I always play the Royal opus
I'm not really much of a real opus fan
Kailas just kicked the night away from
there and prepare Queen to e7 which will
be quite deadly if he goes here Queen to
e7 will be quite deadly ax I think I
don't really see a good move for him but
okay night the b5 is possible but I will
play Queen to b4 so I think it's okay
well the thing I dislike about real hope
is is that it's a positional opening
well like most e4 e5 games it's it's a
positional opening and well I prefer
tactical games to positional ones okay
so I definitely don't want to nice move
to play but I don't think I don't think
black can defend really so let's just
push here
[Music]
Demetria Demetria disagrees with me a
lot
okay so he is attacking this rook which
is quite annoying
so I'll just play g6 Demetria is always
disagreeing with me
okay so now we'll capture here since we
have this g6 we don't have to be afraid
go into c4 well sure point to c4 is
probably winning but I do like my
position and I'm not really in a hurry
to trade Queens
although yeah now it's pretty
straightforward so I'm even gonna give
up this point if he's interested in
capturing it okay but now this is well
completely over
ok after 1 at 1 we have Trotter sappal
Trotter supple didn't get a chance to
play yet and then I think it's it's
mating 1 2 3 and then well maybe maybe a
game or two and then well I have to end
the stream since I do have a video to
make for today and well there are other
things to do besides playing chess well
not every day but sometimes some time
you can play chess for the entire day
I'm gonna play e5 III like Queen v6
against efore but not be v produces
games that are more interesting I think
okay so let's go for this Russian gambit
again and see how our friend the Trotter
sepal who is playing extremely fast
deals with this okay so I'm just gonna
capture here and see what our friend
thinks about this yeah does he like it
probably probably the Queen she doesn't
like it okay bye Vishal I hope we can
play some more at least next time
and the Trotters Apple has experienced
the Russian gambit and its fullest so
it's a it's not an easy position for
what the BN
well there's actually a very simple way
to refute the Russian gambit but I'm not
gonna say what is it you have to find
out for yourselves and we have mate in
one two three next in line who a very
strong player or twenty to fifty player
so I will choose might be six against a
very strong player will go c5 mmm okay
but since he played Knight to c3 then I
won't play c5 and just try to set up our
pieces just Castle here
and he goes for this 'if I push I don't
know if this is good I haven't seen it
that often it probably is but I'm just
gonna capture here and see what he makes
of it okay so probably on Knight to d5
he wants to play c4 but moving my knife
from f6 isn't something that I want to
do but probably have to although he can
probably make some ideas of Bishop
captures an 87 although he's not
interested in something like that so I'm
just gonna play h6 here
uh he's gonna go for this very nice hmm
very nice I forgot my bishop was there
well we can't strap as Queen so not a
lot of moves we can play since we are
down a piece that was that there was a
pure blunder if we don't achieve
anything in the next couple of moves I
will resign this maybe but I don't think
so maybe maybe with maybe with h5 we can
create some some ideas but I highly
highly doubt doubt it his queen is
somewhat misplaced there but well I am a
piece down ya rope to f3 was my next
idea but he played nitro h2
so it's very very hard to play anything
here
so I'm just gonna push with g5 don't
really see anything else I can play this
is called over pushing it means when
you're losing you're just pushing and
trying to do make anything happen it's a
nice move it does allow this but I don't
think if it if I accomplished anything
by it if he plays Queen d4 which he
won't I kind of do have this move which
could be good but doesn't seem like it's
a good move I will play it though
but after king gage one I don't really
see anything that can do not really
yeah King H one and now he's threatening
Queen g6 so I have to stop this somehow
and it's really not a lot of ways you
can stop this if I play rook to f6 if I
play rook to f6 he will capture my rook
so I'll go Ruby eight but that allows
this check I do have to sacrifice my
rook I think here just to continue this
game somehow he will bring the Queen
back of course because he has to keep
his Queen in the line of or maybe he
doesn't
maybe I just think he does okay he's
down to 20 seconds but I think g3 solves
all of his problems
yeah g3 is the move to play definitely
he's gonna try and well end this very
soon but I managed to trick him somehow
but a very a very hard game against
mating three one two three
I did wonder a piece there but I managed
to get some counter play okay we have
Jeptha next I don't think I played okay
money bonnie is next
I haven't played Bonnie yet and his
first in line
well Nikhil a both of us had a very
little time on the clock so eventually
what was a blitz game turned into a
bullet game so and Bonnie is also
playing really fast so Bishop to see
wand it's quite a move I'm gonna play
this and rear up my Bishop to g4
maybe age five and he does play it
interesting ideas here
I'm really interested in what he will do
yeah it was almost like a bullet game
okay but this drops the Queen
unfortunately for Bonnie oh it's a
bullet game oh man I didn't realize it
was a bullet game that that's too bad
that's oh I thought it was a normal game
I just realized it was a bullet when I
had 10 seconds left
okay Jeff dies next okay on it I will
check your challenge next although I
mean if there's really something wrong
with the leeches challenges going in
chronological order then that's that's
really bad okay I'm it is next on it is
next whatever happens on it is next
[Music]
and again this Bishop g5 move okay let's
see what happens if I capture here I'm
really interested to see
seems like a weird move this Bishop to
g5 I've never seen it
Kaiba Tron III already said that well
since I've been streaming for so long I
will play a couple of people that
haven't played even one game so far but
I will play you Kappa Tron yeah Bishop
g5 does seem to be a blunder but after I
capture the bishop he will probably
capture my bishop my knight or even
capture with the Queen I don't know
probably capturing with the Queen would
be better as he is attacking the rook
but I just accepted this to see what
would happen yeah not now Queen can
probably capture here
although capturing the knight probably
is pretty good as well it's hard to say
I mean white didn't lose a piece or
anything maybe a pawn depending what
move move order he chooses
so now capturing here would be quite a
blunder because I have to capture here
and after Queen captures here well I
have to play c6 whether I want to or not
and now 95 move is coming which is quite
nice actually so attacking that c6 pawn
so this seems like my only idea
how do I get this rock out this is very
annoying for me I could try something
like this and then f6 but it's well not
a position I would like to play although
I could play Queen d6 and then Queen to
d5 and exchange Queens probably probably
this would be good for black and I have
to be careful this f7 point is weak now
that I've moved up from f8 your sorrow
is sleeping I don't know I called him he
said he would come okay so let's let's
try and exchange Queens here and of
course she doesn't allow it but now I'm
defending the C pawn twice so I can play
this move Knight to d7 actually okay I
will capture here so we're moved to play
now he has to capture this or he doesn't
but well it's an interesting idea well
my queen isn't attacked so so I'm just
gonna attack his queen oh he's attacking
f7 but okay she's attacking f7 with a
rock in the night I don't think that
should be much of a problem I will allow
him to capture it but probably best move
is capturing and c5 yeah that's probably
the best move so now I'm gonna offer the
exchange of Queens and then this CC bond
is weak he's not interested in this and
why would he be okay there's no threat
of any Knight to d7 or something he
wants to play rook to d3
and I don't blame him well he just
resigned he missed matin one
actually it's question if I would see it
okay we definitely said okay that our
next challenger is since I don't see him
okay this is a five minute game we said
we would only play three minute game
okay we have Amy of imagination next
yeah it seems we both missed it I wasn't
expecting it and well he of course
wasn't expecting it either on it there
is no challenge on it
mm here you can see all the challenges
here no challenge hold on it's mm so do
check if you if you really did make a
challenge
okay Amy of email of aiming ttan it's
quite a quite a user name okay we'll see
if amy of aiming ten is interested in
playing some russian gambit but he isn't
so we will go for the four Knights
defense uh probably we should be seven
no I haven't cancelled the challenge I
haven't cancelled any challenges so far
except ratchets because he challenged to
a correspondence game it's a very nice
move
protecting his Bishop I I would like to
get this Bishop okay so I don't think
putting his rook and a two is something
to look forward to so I will go H 692 h7
and then Knight to g5 and if I can
exchange this night and this Bishop then
I think I'll be good there are no light
squared bishop sin anymore so I can even
push f5
it's a nice move so there are a nice
move
he did trick me into winning my dark
square bishop so we'll see how it goes
you know this is a eater this is some
super crazy attack I'm not aware of or
he decided to give his rooks instead of
instead of the night for the bishop well
unless unless I see something else I
will consider this to be a blunder
so probably queen h5 now no not even
that
okay you did win that pawn
congratulations
I kind of want his night to go back to
d5 so so the Queen doesn't have that
square and and not only now push f5
Immy of aiming tennis playing some very
weird moves
okay so I definitely want to play f4
here giving up upon here that isn't
really an issue played this and I think
I think this is very good for me I'm
threatening Knight to f3 winning his
queen but well I'm still threatening it
okay this is well okay I have time for
one more game and then I really have to
end the stream so I will try to make it
a player
okay I will play two more games let's
see okay we have on each mm but this is
a new challenge
there wasn't a challenge so far okay on
it let's play since I know you've been
waiting for a long time okay and cope
with next and that's it for this stream
I would really like to play for hours
more but it's it's not that easy and
again I'm talking and I can't I play the
French again and I never play the French
I have no idea how to play the French
I'm just gonna you know put my pieces
out and hope for the best
but since since there are so many of you
here you can easily create your own
tournament on VHS and see who is the
best but I will make a tournament
tomorrow morning so everyone who is
interested is welcome to join it will be
at 9 a.m. and well it will be a
tournament between subscribers and
probably pretty fun ok I probably have
to capture on here but I kind of don't
don't want to
Queen here okay I like this move
preparing all sorts of trouble so I
definitely want to move this Bishop from
g5 so probably yeah that's that's a nice
move which is gonna play here try to
exchange it and if the knight moves the
knight will probably play next and stop
me from playing rook to e8 which is
which is a good idea but I'm gonna try
and try and control this line this way
so after rook rook e1 I'm gonna play
Queen to f8 and still control the line
random fact I think you already asked me
that once in the comments but I could be
wrong
you're from Croatia as well okay what to
play here what's the threat I don't
really see the threat but I'm just gonna
play my Queen here control as many
places as I can which city random facts
ah major Maria I played it there a
couple of times
it's a pretty good move attacking that
b7 pawn and the knight is pretty strong
there plus on it has a lot more time
than me I should really try and play
faster night if f5 is probably coming
Queen f5 seems like like a pretty deadly
move I have to make some room for my
queen
so probably Quincy eight check is coming
on it is playing good chess winning that
b7 pawn it's quite nice although
although on it is looking for a better
move in Quincy 8 and I don't really
think this is a better move but we'll
see it very well could be a better move
okay it's winning the pawn definitely
well if on it is interested in winning a
pawn that is because this Queen that you
want could be nasty no I'm not a
grandmaster
far from it
yeah I know the club
it's an interesting idea
okay Queen is protecting here so let's
just attack the night Queen f5 check is
not possible because of my night here so
- is pretty nicely placed on h4 Queen to
c7 are defending okay and threatening to
capture on f7 so it's a nice move
a nice move indeed but as it usually is
a great game by on it
Thank You Python for subscribing okay we
said Kobo and this is it for today's
stream but I definitely invite all of
you because I'm streaming for three and
a half hours and well I do have other
things to do like you know eat and walk
my dog and make chess videos and such
things but I do invite all of you to
join a tournament I will create a
tournament and I'm not really sure if HS
will allow me to name my tournament so
you know which tournament it is but I
will livestream it so you can just come
to the live stream and ask me which
tournament to join yeah tomorrow at 9
a.m. it will be a subscriber tournament
it will be a 1-hour tournament maybe so
you know it doesn't take too long it and
everybody can play so there are I've
played a couple of strong players on the
stream so it should be pretty pretty
interesting
yeah 9 a.m. 9 a.m.
in Croatia it's it's 1 p.m. now 1 p.m.
in 10 minutes so you should calculate it
over to your timezone my job I work as a
graphic designer in this company here in
my city and I design well you know
flyers posters websites anything really
that can be designed
I'm sure you know it it's cut that said
you had you had two of those in
chocolates I think one is although yeah
I still think you have two in chocolates
and we're not gonna go g5 but there
really isn't a better move
no I don't program programming is well
something I always wanted to do but
never really never really learned it
enough so just you know basic HTML and
some CSS but mostly we use well at the
moment we were using WordPress for or
for all our services so it's not really
that much of a design Kobo is playing
like a beast I have no idea what to play
here since this pawn is very strong hmm
what to play here I think that I kind of
think I have to play rock to g8 no not
rock the h8 rock the g8 I would say
okay this does allow him to play g3 now
but it doesn't matter
I'll get this f6 pawn and it'll be okay
I'm playing the first board for credit
see
it's okay move okay this is just a
blunder I think
okay and I guess I guess it would be
nice to end today's stream with a queen
sacrifice so let's let's just play Queen
captures on h2
that's a nice game kobu very nice game
and you know got me worried there
well that's it for today's stream thank
you all for joining in and think all for
playing like I said a couple of very
strong players and well what's most
important is that you enjoy chess and
well that you look forward to improving
your game so yeah that's it for today
you are all welcome to check out my
video I will post it somewhere I don't
know maybe in an hour or hour and a half
depends on when I finish it oh it's acid
ah hello the one who typed I
think he typed karyakin for every
question on the quiz positive grommet so
yeah unfortunately like I said I have to
end my stream now and I'll see you
tomorrow be sure to join in on the
tournament at 9 a.m.
are you yes it was you although I did I
do think you typed karaoking on that one
question and got it right actually so
yeah that's it and I'll see you tomorrow
and feel free to check out my video
today it will be a very nice game
between Michael Tao and a player of
surprise so see you soon